over the last six months my team and I
have been checking out your best
restaurant nominations all over the
country and tonight the competition
continues with one of the Britain's most
popular cuisines Indian curry is a
national obsession and these days we
will expect really high standards from
our Indian restaurants I spent a lot of
time out in India and learn for myself
what real good Indian food is all about
so tonight's restaurant lovely good to
impress away from over 2,000 Indian
nominations I've chosen what I think are
the best to to fight it out for a place
in the semi-finals
tonight from Bradford the curry capital
of the north its Prashad I know they're
going head to head with world-famous
cuisine from a London heavyweight the
brilliant in South orb come on my father
over top chef in India used to cook for
the Maharajah's this competition could
be the ultimate test for both my ending
contenders there we have battles the
very end because only one restaurant can
come out on top
to find that winner both contenders will
face a free challenging test starting
with a coach low of 30 hungry diners who
arrive an order all at once first
they'll descend on the Patel family who
run tiny Prashad in bradford there are
over 60 Indian restaurants alone in this
fantastic city but this one is somewhat
special the smallest restaurant this
competition but I think is gonna give
the big boys a serious run for the money
hello Bobby I've never had a vegetarian
restaurant in the competition so I'm so
excited I'm happy as well just under
half an hour my donors gonna be here
they think they're coming for an amazing
lamb bhuna so convert them this place
used to be a launderette now it's a 22
seat restaurant run by Kashi Patel with
her son Bobby and his wife me now being
vegetarian what we put passion into
other restaurants offer a side dish we
have to really step up we really have to
bring the flavors out give them
something totally different
incredibly me now the head chef had
never cooked professionally until she
married Bobby moved to England and
joined his mum in the kitchen six years
ago she is not my daughter-in-law she's
my daughter
I can't describe how much I love cooking
whatever I cook it's from my heart it's
delicious one mouthful then I feel like
I'm back in Mumbai the exact same for my
diners please
now I can't leave that to waste I've got
to eat some more that I'm sorry we have
a huge drive huge ambition we didn't
come into this business thinking we're
gonna make loads of money we came into
the business about showing the world how
good we are at food now they must prove
it
because my 30 diners are just minutes
away though expecting a perfect meal and
everyone must be served in just two
hours the pressures on you big time and
I know this means a lot I can see it on
your face but here's your chance now to
really stand your hold on this
competition good luck
you